ahora lo que voy a hacer es una
presentación de una de las herramientas
más poderosas para integrar esta es una
herramienta que si tienes a tu
disposición y la sabes usar muy bien más
allá del examen entonces te vas a volver
muy muy bueno haciendo integrales de
hecho te vas a volver casi casi un gurú
para las integrales entonces déjame
déjame explicarte un poco a qué me
refiero con esto pero lo primero que
vamos a hacer es recordar la regla de
producto para derivar supongamos que
queremos derivar efe x
por g x
vale entonces vamos a tomar la derivada
de este producto la derivada con
respecto a x df x x gtx ahora el regla
regla del producto lo que nos dice es
que esto es lo mismo que tomar la
derivada del primer término la derivada
de f prima de x
multiplicando la por la segunda función
y sumándole la primera función sin
derivar f x multiplicada por la derivada
de la segunda función
se prima de x
sale ahora si integramos a ambos lados
de esta ecuación es que es algo que
podemos hacer verdad estamos haciendo
álgebra lo que hacemos de un lado de la
ecuación lo hacemos del otro lado de la
ecuación
entonces integramos los dos lados de la
ecuación e integramos el lado izquierdo
la integral se cancela con la derivada
entonces regresamos a la expresión
original nos quedaría simplemente f x x
g x
y en el lado derecho hay que integrar
cada uno de los sumandos nos queda nos
queda la integral
nos queda la integral de f prima de x
por gd x
dx
más la integral del segundo sumando que
es la integral de fx porque prima de x
de x
ahora lo que voy a hacer te va a parecer
un poco arbitrario pero bueno bueno si
si es un poco arbitrario para que te
digo que no pero bueno lo que voy a
hacer es tomar cualquiera de estos
términos digamos este este el de la
izquierda y lo voy a pasar al lado
izquierdo de la igualdad entonces voy a
restar este término de los dos lados
entonces este término de acá déjame
marcarlo con otro color para que quede
un poco más claro este término de acá lo
voy a poner aquí que es la integral de
fx
porque prima de x
v x
es igual
a este término voy a regresar al
amarillo es igual a efe x por gd x
a eso de ahí hay que restarle este
término entonces es menos este que voy a
poner en azul - menos la integral de f
prima de x
borge x
de x entonces que acabo de hacer parece
ser que simplemente y bueno si estoy más
que nada jugando verdad con la expresión
de la regla del producto entonces a lo
mejor dice saja y bueno esto se ve como
que muy coqueto pero esto de qué sirve
bueno hay tema entonces lo que
esencialmente dice lo que esencialmente
hice fue probar esta fórmula que estoy
en marcando
esta de acá tiene un nombre especial y
se llama integración por partes y casi
siempre a mí se me olvida cómo es porque
si te das cuenta tiene muchas como cosas
complicadas y entonces esta es una de
las técnicas más importantes te voy a
enseñar un lugar en donde se usa
supongamos que queremos tomar la
integral de pues digamos x
jose no de x
de equis
ahora cualquier herramienta que tenemos
hasta ahorita no nos va a servir porque
pues fíjate no encontramos la derivada
ni de coseno ni de x por ningún lado
entonces no podemos hacer una
sustitución una integral por sustitución
pero pues tampoco podemos integrarlo
simplemente como un polinomio entonces
cuando te encuentres integrales de este
estilo lo que lo que podemos hacer y una
de las herramientas más más buenas para
resolver integrales es utilizar
integración por partes
entonces integración por partes nos dice
que si hay una integral de una función y
la derivada de otra función entonces
podemos utilizar esta fórmula y con un
poco de suerte simplificar entonces lo
que voy a hacer lo que voy a hacer y
bueno ahorita te explico mi proceso de
pensamiento porque pues no no es
inmediato pero lo que voy a hacer es lo
siguiente lo que queremos es o sea la
idea es que queremos simplificar la
expresión vale entonces aquí hay un
coseno que es medio complicado verdad
pero qué podemos hacer vamos a asumir
que x efe sf x que coseno de x es que
prima de x claro pudimos haberlo hecho
de otra forma pero como por la razón por
la cual lo vamos a hacer así o sea por
la razón por la cual fx es x ig prima de
x es cosa de x es que después vamos a
querer tomar la derivada de f la
derivada de x se hace 1 verdad entonces
hace mucho más simple y después vamos a
querer integrarse prima de x es decir
vamos a querer encontrar la primitiva de
coseno de x y la anti derivada de cosas
no de x es simplemente seno de aquí que
puse es más o menos igual de complicado
que coseno entonces no estamos agregar
agregándole complejidad del problema
puedes intentarlo al revés pero bueno si
ponemos aquí la equis y queremos
encontrar su primitiva nos queda x
cuadrado entre dos veces eso es más o
menos la intuición para utilizar
integración por partes pero va vamos a
asumir que fx es x que prima de x es
cosa de x entonces fx
a ver voy a marcar con amarillo para que
sea un poco más divertido entonces fx es
x verdad
entonces aquí tenemos un f x le ponemos
equis y ahora vamos a suponer que eje x
o más bien dijimos kg prima dx es coseno
de equis y entonces quienes gx o sea que
primer coseno de x entonces quienes gx
pues es la primitiva de coseno de x
entonces el seno de x entonces lo pongo
por acá gx es seno de x ahora puede ser
un poco confuso déjame escribirlo acá
aquí abajo al ladito para ver lo que
estamos bueno para ver lo que estoy
diciendo entonces estoy diciendo que fx
es igual a equis y estoy diciendo que gx
es igual a x y porque decidí que xe seno
de x pues porque dije que eje prima de x
era coseno de x entonces gx es su
primitiva es decir seno de x
ahora bueno si la derivada de una
función es jose no es porque la función
es coseno esto es por algo que
memorizamos es algo que tal vez probemos
después pero vamos a usar eso por el
momento entonces la fórmula nos dice que
pongamos menos la integral
de la derivada de fx quienes fx
fx es x y su derivada es uno y fíjate
que aquí se simplificó hay que
multiplicar después por gd x ya dijimos
que gdx sx1 le ponemos seno del pse 9 x
de equis y pues aquí te puedes dar
cuenta que esto ya se simplificó porque
esto simplemente es la integral de seno
de x entonces esto es igual a x seno de
x esto es el primer término de aquí
menos y cuál es la integral de seno de x
bueno la derivada de bueno y te va
déjame cambiar un poquito los signos
para que sea más fácil vamos a poner
aquí un menos aquí un menos
multiplicando entonces se vuelve más
entonces ahora de aquí pues ya es muy
fácil verdad porque cuál es la primitiva
de m
x entonces qué función cuando la
derivamos la menos seno de equipos
coseno de x pues ponemos coseno de x y
recuerda que nunca se nos tienen que
olvidar el mace
ahora simplemente lo que hicimos es
utilizar la regla del producto para
encontrar esta fórmula de integración
por partes hay muchos lugares que para
aprender se ponen acrónimos como una
vaca vestida de uniforme y así pero a mí
me gusta mucho más encontrarla así
porque tiene mucho más sentido si te das
cuenta lo único que tenemos que hacer es
pensar que viene de la regla del
producto y no tenemos que memorizar la a
lo mejor te la quieras memorizar para el
examen para no perder tiempo en deducir
la pero cuando ya se es cálculo después
así varios años después no tienes por
qué haberte el aprendido simplemente
bueno lo que yo hago es asociar que
integrar por partes es simplemente una
deducción de la regla del producto y
entonces todo tiene mucho sentido y la
puedo encontrar sin tener que buscarlo
en un libro y así bueno esto es más o
menos una introducción de integrales por
partes en la siguiente presentación
quiero hacerte más ejemplos todos los
que quepan en 10 minutos para que nos
volvamos muy buenos resolviendo
integrales por partes nos vemos hasta
entonces